for the first time in Israel's history
the Supreme Court has nullified a basic
law one of the series of laws that
serves as the country's Unwritten
constitution on Monday a divided Court
overturned the reasonableness standard
Bill eight judges voted in favor and
seven
against Justice Minister Yu LaVine who
is one of the architects of the law
slammed the ruling saying the decision
to publish during the war is the
opposite of the
needed for the
fighters but opposition leader y Leed
voiced support of the Court's decision
blaming the divisions for leading to the
October 7th
attacks the Supreme Court of Israel said
it its voice today raised its voice
today in a very clear and Loud way and
put an end to all the What's called the
legal or juristic reform that Nan's
Government tried to to imp
Israel's parliament the knesset approved
the bill in
July the vote was 64 to zero after
opposition lawmakers boycotted the
vote and stormed out some shouting shame
towards the
government moments later there was a
show of force from tens of thousands of
protesters some escalated to violence
and
arrests the bill eliminated a Doctrine
under which the court could override
some government decisions and block
appointments supporters claimed the
Court's use of power was undemocratic
but opponents said the Court's ability
to block parliamentary overreach was an
essential part of Israel's system of
legal checks and
balances the bill was the first piece of
a larger package of judicial reforms and
its reversal now calls the rest of the
government's proposed reforms into
question although a crushing blow to the
coalition government people who have
been tirelessly protesting for months
will see this as a win and although
language here has been about Unity
during Israel's war on Gaza the Supreme
Court's decision could once again create
a widening Gulf between the Coalition
and public opinion Laura Khan Al jazer
occupied East
Jerusalem make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jaer